>> THANKS FOR JOINING US.
"AC360" START NOW.
>> WE BEGIN WITH BREAKING NEWS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL CALLED THE
HIGHEST REACHING APPROPRIATION.
THERE'S NEW REPORTING IN "THE
WASHINGTON POST" THIS EVENING
CITING FOUR FAMILIAR WITH THE
INVESTIGATION.
THE HEADLINE, "JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATING TRUMP'S
ACTIONS IN JANUARY 6 CRIMINAL
PROBE."
THE PROSECUTORS HAVE ASKED HOURS
OF DETAILED QUESTIONS ABOUT
MEETINGS TRUMP LED IN DECEMBER
2020 AND JANUARY 2021.
THIS PRESSURE CAMPAIGN ON PENCE
TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION WHAT I
UNDERSTAND INSTRUCTIONS TRUMP
GAVE HIS LAWYERS AND ADVISERS
ABOUT FAKE ELECTORS AND SENDING
ELECTORS BACK TO THE STATE.
AS THE FORMER PRESIDENT RETURNED
TO WASHINGTON SINCE LEADING
OFFICE, WE'LL HAVE SOME OF WHAT
HE SAID SHORTLY.
FIRST WHAT MERRICK GARLAND TOLD
LESTER HOLT WHEN ASKED WHEN
INDICTING A FORMER PRESIDENT AND
POSSIBLE PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
AGAIN MIGHT TEAR THE COUNTRY
APART.
>> WE PURSUE JUSTICE WITHOUT
FEAR OR FAVOR.
WE INTEND TO HOLD EVERYONE,
ANYONE WHO IS CRIMINALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE EVENTS
SURROUNDING JANUARY 6th OR ANY
ATTEMPT TO INTERFERE WITH THE
LAWFUL TRANSFER OF POWER FROM
ONE ADMINISTRATION TO ANOTHER
ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
WE DON'T PAY ANY ATTENTION TO
OTHER ISSUES WITH RESPECT TO
THAT.
>> Reporter: SO IF DONALD TRUMP
WERE TO BECOME A CANDIDATE FOR
PRESIDENT AGAIN, THAT WOULD NOT
CHANGE YOUR SCHEDULE OR HOW YOU
MOVE FORWARD OR DON'T MOVE
FORWARD?
>> I'LL SAY AGAIN THAT WE WILL
HOLD ACCOUNTABLE ANYONE WHO IS
CRIMINALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
ATTEMPTING WITH THE LEGITIMATE
TRANSFER OF POWER FROM ONE
ADMINISTRATION TO THE NEXT.
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL VOWED
TWICE TO HOLD RESPONSIBLE ANYONE
TRYING TO INTERFERE WITH THE
TRANSFER OF POWER.
CNN HAD SIMILAR ROARING EARLIER
TODAY, JOSH.
YOUR ARTICLE GOES A LITTLE
DEEPER WITH DETAILS ABOUT
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS BEING ASKED
BY GRAND JURY INVESTIGATORS, AS
WELL AS PHONE RECORDS BEING
SEIZED.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US?
>> TWO OF THE MAIN THINGS WE
KNOW, IN THE GRAND JURY GOING ON
IN WASHINGTON, THEY ARE
PRESENTING EVIDENCE OF WHAT PRUM
WAS DOING IN THE WEEKS LEADING
UP TO JANUARY 6th, WHO HE WAS
MEETING WITH, WHAT HE SAYING TO
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE AND VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE'S AIDES AND IT
SAYS THEY WERE LOOKING AT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AND HIS
BEHAVIOR AND CONDUCT.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW THAT WILL END
BUT THEY ARE DEEPLY INTERESTED
IN WHAT HE WAS DOING A FEW
MONTHS AGO THEY SUBPOENAED PHONE
RECORDS FOR HIS TOP AIDES,
INCLUDING MARK MEADOWS, FOR
ANOTHER PART OF THIS
INVESTIGATION.
YOU HAVE PROSECUTORS WHO ARE
LOOKING AT MORE RIOTERS IN THE
CAPITOL, LOOKING AT SOME OF
THESE MILITANT GROUPS, FRINGE
GROUPS AND OUTSIDE FOLKS AND
THEY'RE HONING IN NOW MORE ON
WHAT THE FORMERS PRESIDENT AND
HIS LAWYERS DID ON THE DAYS
LEADING UP TO JANUARY 6th.
>> AND YOUR INVESTIGATION POINTS
TO TWO TRACKS.
>> YEAH, THEY'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHETHER THE FORMER
PRESIDENT INSTRUCTED HIS LAWYERS
TO CARRY OUT THE SCHEME, WHAT
HIS ROLE WAS IN THAT AND
OBVIOUSLY OBSTRUCTING A
GOVERNMENT PROCEEDING AT THE
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6th.
BUT WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT, IS WHAT EXACTLY WAS
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S ROLE?
YOU HAVE THESE LAWYERS LIKE JOHN
EASTMAN AND RUDY GIULIANI AND
OTHER OUTSIDE ADVISERS DOING
THIS ON THEIR OWN VOLITION OR
WAS THE FORMER PRESIDENT
INTIMATELY INVOLVED?
AND THE DAYS LEADING UP TO
JANUARY 6th, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WAS EXERTING ALL KIND
OF PRESSURE ON MIKE PENCE AND
OTHERS TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
THEY BROUGHT IN HIS CHIEF OF
STAFF AND CHIEF LAWYER AND SPENT
HOURS WITH THEM BOTH TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE ASPECTS OF THAT
PRESSURE CAMPAIGN.
>> IN TERMS OF TIMELINE, DO YOU
KNOW HOW FAST THIS INVESTIGATION
IS MOVING?
IS IT POSSIBLE THE FORMER
PRESIDENT COULD BE SUBPOENAED
HIMSELF?
WOULD THAT ACTUALLY TAKE PLACE?
>> IT'S CERTAINLY POSSIBLE THEY
COULD SUBPOENA PEOPLE IN THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S ORBIT.
THEY COULD GET RECORDS TO HIM.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW FAST THIS IS
MOVING.
BY SOME ACCOUNTS IT HAS APPEARED
PUBLICLY THE D.O.J. HAS BEEN
BEHIND THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
ON PARTS OF THIS AT LEAST.
THERE ARE MULTIPLE REPORTS THAT
THEY WERE SURPRISED AT SOME OF
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON'S TESTIMONY,
FOR EXAMPLE, AND THEY FOCUSED
MORE ON SOMEBODY OUTSIDE THE
RIOTERS.
IT SEEMS WHENEVER THEY'VE GOTTEN
MORE EVIDENCE, THEY'RE COMING IN
CLOSER TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT
AND HIS CIRCLE.
>> THANKS SO MUCH.
JOINING US NOW IS JENNIFER
RODGERS AND CHRIS WALLACE.
JENNIFER, YOU AND I WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS BEFORE.
IT'S UNLIKELY THEY WOULD
SUBPOENA THE FORMER PRESIDENT IF
HE IS A TARGET.
>> FOR TESTIMONY.
THEY COULD TRY TO GET DOCUMENTS
OR DEVICES BUT THEY WON'T
SUBPOENA HIM FOR TESTIMONY
BECAUSE HE IS A TARGET.
THEY JUST DON'T SUBPOENA
TARGETS.
AND HE KNOWS HE'S THEIR TARGET
AND YOU HAVE THIS STANCE WHERE
THEY WOULD HAVE TO GIVE IMMUNITY
AND THEY'RE NOT GOING DO THAT.
>> WHAT IS YOUR REPORTING OF
WHERE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
IS?
>> I THINK THEY HAVE SHIFTED TO
THIS MIKE PENCE PRESSURE
CAMPAIGN.
THEY'RE FOCUSING IN ON TRUMP AND
HIS CONDUCT AS OPPOSED TO PEOPLE
AROUND HIM AND THE ONES
OPERATIONALLY.
>> AND TO JENNIFER'S POINT, THE
PROSECUTORS IN THIS CASE
FOCUSING ON THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S PRESSURE CAMPAIGN,
GARLAND SORT OF MADE A NOD TO
THAT AS WELL TODAY.
>> THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SEEMS
TO BE ON THE CASE AND SECONDLY,
THEY WANT TO BE SEEN AS BEING ON
THE CASE.
THEY SEEM TO BE LAGGING BEHIND
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE AND
THE CASE WITH GEORGIA AND
INTERFERENCE IN THE ELECTION
THERE.
ON MONDAY WE FOUND OUT THEY HAD
A GRAND JURY AND WE HEARD
TESTIMONY FROM TWO TOP AIDES TO
MIKE PENCE, YOU HAD THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AGREEING TO DO THE
INTERVIEW TODAY AND TWICE IN THE
INTERVIEW HE SAID "WE'RE MOVING
URGENTLY."
ONE OTHER THING IN THE STORY IN
THE "WASHINGTON POST" THAT IS
BREAKING TONIGHT THAT IT
SPECIFICALLY SAYS THAT THEY
SEIZED THE RECORDS OF MARK
MEADOWS AND OTHER PEOPLE AND
SPECIFICALLY SAID THEY DID IT IN
APRIL, MONTHS BEFORE THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE.
SO CLEARLY SOMEBODY IN JUSTICE
FROM MERRICK GARLAND ON DOWN IS
TRYING TO SAY WE ARE HOT ON THIS
CASE, DON'T THINK THAT WE'RE
LAGGING BEHIND.
>> JENNIFER, ON THE PHONY
ELECTORS ARE THE QUESTION OF HOW
INVOLVED WAS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IN THAT.
WAS IT HIS ATTORNEY EASTMAN AND
RUDY GIULIANI GOING OFF AND
DOING THIS, YOU KNOW, LARGELY ON
THEIR OWN?
HOW MUCH ARE THEY ABLE TO GET
THE RECORDS OF GIULIANI, RECORDS
OF EASTMAN?
>> SO IT'S REALLY HARD TO KNOW
FROM JUST PHONE RECORDS WHO IS
TALKING TO WHOM FOR HOW MUCH
TIME AND WHAT WAS SAID.
IN ORDER TO GET TO HOW MUCH THE
FORMER PRESIDENT KNEW ABOUT THAT
SCHEME AND HOW MUCH HE WAS
DIRECTING IT AS OPPOSED TO JUST
BEING UPDATED ON IT, THEY'RE
REALLY GOING TO HAVE TO GET
SOMEONE DEALING DIRECTLY WITH
HIM TO TESTIFY.
THAT PROBABLY MEANS GIVING ONE
OF THESE PEOPLE IMMUNITY
ULTIMATELY SO THEY CAN TALK
ABOUT THE CONVERSATIONS WHERE
TRUMP WAS BEING UPDATED OR MAYBE
HE WAS ACTUALLY RUNNING THE
SHOW.
WE KNOW HE KNEW ABOUT THE SCHEME
BUT DON'T KNOW HOW INVOLVED.
>> Reporter: THINGS LIKE THE
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE AND
HOW DOES THAT PLAY IN WITH
EASTMAN?
>> TO THE EXTENT THEY'RE SEIZING
DOCUMENTS THAT MIGHT HAVE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH TRUMP, THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO SEEK TESTIMONY
THAT INVOLVES COMMUNICATION,
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO SORT
THROUGH THAT.
IF THE COMMUNICATION IS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF FURTHERING A CRIME OR
FRAUD AND D.O.J. WOULD ARGUE IT
WAS, THEY CAN SEE THAT
MATERIAL ALL OF THAT TAKES TIME.
>> I WANT TO HEAR MORE ABOUT
WHAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID
ABOUT THE CRITICISM THAT THE
D.O.J. ISN'T MOVING QUICKLY
ENOUGH.
>> THE REASON THERE IS THIS
SPECULATION AND UNCERTAINTY IS A
FUNDAMENTAL TENET OF WHAT WE DO
AS PROSECUTORS AND INVESTIGATORS
IS TO DO IS OUTSIDE OF THE
PUBLIC EYE.
WE DO IT, ONE, TO PROTECT THE
CIVIL LIBERTIES OF THE PEOPLE
WE'RE INVESTIGATING AND THE
SECOND IS TO ENSURE THE SUCCESS
AND INTEGRITY OF OUR
INVESTIGATION.
>> IT'S INTERESTING, CHRIS, WHAT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL NOT ONLY
WAS TRYING TO CONVEY TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC BUT THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE SPECIFICALLY.
>> CLEARLY HE IS FEELING SOME
HEAT AND -- I MEAN, HE SAYS
WE'RE DOING IT OUTSIDE OF THE
EYE OF THE PUBLIC BUT THERE HAVE
BEEN A LOT OF LEAKS ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION, LIKE WHO WAS
TESTIFYING BEFORE THE GRAND
JURY.
ON THE ONE HAND THEY'RE SAYING
WE'RE DOING THIS OUTSIDE THE
PUBLIC BUT WE'RE ALSO GOING TO
GET THE WAS IN TO THE PUBLIC.
HE WAS ASKED, MERRICK GARLAND,
ABOUT THE FACT THAT HOW MUCH ARE
YOU GETTING INFORMING FROM THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE AND HE
SAID, LOOK, THEY'RE DOING THE
BIGGEST INVESTIGATION -- ONE OF
THE BIGGEST IN HOUSE HISTORY.
WE'RE DOING THE BIGG